Apple's new Mac Pro is now available to
order online and as you guys can see
right here on my screen you can spec it
up to over fifty thousand dollars for
one machine without the display now
that's been causing quite a bit of an
uproar on the internet and on YouTube
with a lot of people freaking out over
the 50 thousand dollar price tag and a
lot of people saying that Apple is
trying to rip everybody off now is that
the truth is Apple trying to rip you off
or is it actually priced reasonably well
so in this video we're gonna answer that
question right here on my screen I have
six different websites that sell various
configurations of workstation computers
just like the Mac Pro so let's see if
Apple is really trying to rip you off
but before I get into these
configurations I want to remind you a
few key features about the Mac Pro that
stand out compared to other workstations
first of all the design of the Mac Pro
is absolutely amazing especially
compared to all the other workstations
that look like these black boxes that do
not look good you wouldn't want this on
your desktop on top of that the cooling
system on the Mac Pro is absolutely
incredible based on the reviews of the
few youtubers who have gotten their
hands on this it's whisper-quiet almost
all the time you even get really good
i/o even on the base Mac Pro you get
four Thunderbolt three ports which you
have to buy separate adaptors for with
regular workstations and you get two 10
Gigabit Ethernet ports right out of the
box for the base price and then for each
MPX module you add you get four more
Thunderbolt 3 ports on top of that you
also get a crazy good 1,400 watt power
supply on all of the models and finally
Apple has created the afterburner card
which you can only get on the Mac Pro
and it does an excellent job of encoding
and decoding pro res and pro res raw
footage on the macbook pro only now the
best part of all is how easy Apple made
it to configure in order your own Mac
Pro look at this there's only a few
options right here that make it very
very simple to order compared to check
this out
this is Dells order form right here
check out all of these options look at
this imagine you own a company and you
really need some very powerful
workstation computers and you've got to
go through this whole list and you
you have no idea how to configure this
so what's gonna happen is you're gonna
end up hiring somebody or paying
somebody a consultant to go through all
this and tell you exactly what you need
of course you can go through Adele but
they're gonna up charge you they're
gonna try to sell you even better stuff
than you need so you're gonna end up
paying somebody to go through this and
make sure you're getting the best bang
for the buck for what you need so we're
gonna get into the first comparison this
is Dells precision 7920 tower
workstation and as you guys can see we
actually SPECT it up to seventy one
thousand seven hundred thirty three
dollars so let's start off with a
processor let's go all the way down skip
these low-end processors go straight to
the EZ on platinum 80 to 80 mm now this
is the best processor that Dell offers
and if you look here it only goes up to
4.0 gigahertz turbo boost
compared to apples 28 core which goes up
to four point four so apples is actually
better now on to the graphics cards
we're going to choose dual and video
Quadro r-tx 6000 cards which are very
similar in performance to apples to
Radeon Pro Vega twos but the difference
is that the Mac Pro has 32 gigabytes of
video memory compared to only 24 on the
Quadro so you're getting a little bit
more performance with the Mac Pro here
we are at the RAM and we've got one
point five terabytes so that's 12 sticks
of 128 and let's go and choose the same
thing 1 point 5 terabytes 12 sticks of
128 on the Mac Pro now going down to the
hard drives Dell actually forces you to
get a 4 terabyte hard drive in order for
the 1.5 terabytes of memory to work so
we're gonna grab a 4 terabyte hard drive
now we're gonna go down and choose a m2
2 terabyte PCI Express nvme SSD and
we'll go to the third one and choose
another one right there and then on the
mac pro side we just chose simply 4
terabyte SSD right there so let's skip
all these hard drive options now going
down to the network options we're gonna
choose the dual-band Wi-Fi we definitely
want one of those now go into network
cards we're looking for a dual 10
gigabit ethernet but you actually don't
have the option you can only
the five Gigabit Ethernet so I guess
we're gonna have to go with that you
don't even get 10 gig on this machine
now here we're running into an issue
this system supports a maximum of 5 PCI
Express slots with a single CPU so it
looks like we're not even able to get
that Network hard-on so I guess we're
gonna have to take that off so now let's
go down and add some Thunderbolt 3 ports
and we ran into another issue we still
are maxed out on our PCI Express slots
so it looks like we can't even do that
if we want to GPUs on there because it's
using too much of the slots so basically
if we want the extra i/o we actually
have to go back and get a dual CPU which
is gonna be a lot more expensive but
I'll just leave it at this we're getting
a total price of 74 thousand one hundred
and thirty-eight dollars compared to 44
thousand five hundred and ninety-nine
dollars for the Mac Pro and what you're
getting is a really nice looking machine
you're getting four Thunderbolt three
ports on the machine itself and then
four on each MPX module so that's 12
Thunderbolt 3 ports right there and do
all 10 Gigabit Ethernet as well so it's
actually less than the Dell machine now
let's move on to HP's Z 8 g4 workstation
let's go choose a processor looks like
we can choose the same exact one note
that it's still slower than Apple's 28
core we're gonna skip the second
processor we're gonna go down we're
gonna choose the better chassis 1450
watts compared to apples 1,400 watts
going down to ram you can only get a
maximum of 384 right here with this one
processor so we're gonna get the same
thing 384 on the mac pro going down
we're gonna choose the internal m2 we're
going to choose a 2 terabyte and then
choose a second 2 terabyte I'm matching
one so just like apples 4 terabytes
right there we're going to choose the
same exact r-tx 6000 and then for the
second card we're gonna get another r-tx
6000 and that will match apples to ready
on Pro Vega twos we're gonna go down and
get dual 10 Gigabit Ethernet which is
nice that we have this right here which
the Mac Pro already has that and right
here at accessories it actually tells us
that we cannot get the dual port
Thunderbolt 3 adapter
that goes into the PCI Express port
because we don't have the right graphics
option selected these are slower cards
right here but we want the fast ones
that match up with the Mac Pro so it
looks like we cannot even get fun about
three on this HP machine now looking at
the total price we're at forty thousand
dollars compared to twenty five thousand
five hundred and ninety nine on the Mac
Pro so that was for the high-end what if
we actually try to build a more bang for
the buck small business workstations set
up let's go here let's actually choose
the twelve core processor right here
twelve core on the HP twelve core on the
Mac Pro let's go with forty eight
gigabytes of RAM six sticks but eight
gigs which right here on the Mac Pro
forty eight gigabytes well go down and
just choose a one terabyte SSD just like
on the Mac Pro one terabyte and this
time we're just gonna get one of the are
TX 6000 Quadro graphics cards and we'll
just get one other Vega twos on the Mac
Pro as well and we come out with a total
price of fourteen thousand six hundred
and fifty six for the dell and only ten
thousand ninety nine dollars on the Mac
Pro and you're getting a much better
looking machine with a bunch of
Thunderbolt 3 ports now let's move on to
Titan computers right here you'll see we
have the twenty eight core right there
and on the Mac Pro as well going down we
have 256 gigs of ram which it doesn't
perfectly manage the Mac Pro because
it's only four channel RAM compared to
the Mac Pro six channel which is
actually faster than four channel so
we'll go with 256 on the Titan and 384
on the Mac Pro to make it a little bit
more fair let's choose the 1200 watt
power supply because that's the best one
you can get on the Titan come here to
1400 on the Mac Pro we've got dual r-tx
6000 s just like before and we've got
the two Radeon Pro Vega twos we've got
two SSDs that are 2 terabytes each so
it'll match the 4 terabyte SSD on the
Mac Pro and right here we've added the
dual rj45 10 gigabit ethernet adapter
right there now let's get some
Thunderbolt ports and unfortunately
right here it looks like we can only get
Thunderbolt 2 not
three so that kind of sucks but we'll go
with what we can get and looking at the
total price we're at twenty six thousand
six hundred ninety-four dollars compared
to twenty five thousand five hundred
ninety nine dollars that's with a faster
processor more ram 384 instead of 256
and you get the Thunderbolt three ports
and the dual temp Gigabit Ethernet so
you're actually saving money and getting
a better looking machine at the same
time now on to Lenovo is a think station
p9 20 workstation we're actually going
to choose a 12 core because it'll better
match what we get because we can't
choose a 24 core so we're just going to
choose one 12 core and we're gonna match
it up right here on the Mac Pro the 12
core we've got 192 gigabytes of RAM
which we got 192 right here on the Mac
Pro as well
we've got dual r-tx six thousandths and
we got the two Vega twos on the Mac Pro
we got four terabytes of SSD on each
system and unfortunately for the
Ethernet adapter we're not able to get
dual 10 Gigabit Ethernet we can only get
one five gigabit ethernet on the lenovo
and looking at the total price we've got
fourteen thousand eight hundred and four
dollars compared to sixteen thousand
five hundred and ninety nine on the mac
pro now this is the first machine that's
actually cheaper than the mac pro but
then yet again take a look at this the
processor that's 12 cores is actually
slower than the one on the mac pro this
one's actually faster on the mac pro
apples ram is also a little bit faster
than the one on the lenovo and finally
you get a beautiful looking machine with
the mac pro you also get 12 Thunderbolt
3 ports and you get dual 10 Gigabit
Ethernet which you can't get on the
lenovo so i'd say the extra price is
actually worth it for the mac pro
especially how simple it is to order now
moving on to Puget systems the best
processor you can actually get as the 18
core now this is actually a two-year old
18 course or what we're gonna do is
we're gonna match it up with a 16 core
because that system core is brand-new so
it actually performs around the same or
faster than the older 18 core and
because of that the ram is only for
channel so to make it the most fair
we're gonna get 32 gigs on the Puget
system and 32 gigs on the Mac Pro we're
gonna get one RTX 6000 on this machine
so we'll get one Vega 2 on the Mac Pro
and then we'll grab a 2 terabyte SSD and
2 terabyte right there and that brings
us to a total price of nine thousand
four hundred and seventy seven dollars
compared to eleven thousand one hundred
ninety nine dollars for the Mac Pro so
in this comparison it actually makes
sense to buy the puget this is actually
not that bad of a deal but you are
getting a processor that is two years
old compared to the brand-new one on the
Mac Pro so there you go after comparing
all those different configurations we
can see that Apple is actually not
ripping you off they're actually
competitively priced and in some cases
they're actually cheaper than the other
Windows workstations with newer hardware
the really nice design a lot more
Thunderbolt 3 ports you get built-in and
dual 10 Gigabit Ethernet and the order
page is so simple that almost anybody
can go in here configure the Mac Pro by
it and have it shipped to their door and
even better you can upgrade the RAM
yourself Apple actually posted a video
on YouTube on how to do that yourself so
we're gonna post a link down below for
the best Ram that we recommend for this
system so based on all of that Apple is
actually not ripping you off with the
Mac Pro it's actually a pretty good deal
and it looks really good as well now we
actually ordered our very own Mac Pro
it's the twelve thousand dollar model so
if you want to see some in-depth testing
with that make sure to tap the like
button and click the circle above to
subscribe so you don't miss out on that
check out those two videos right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]